everybody loves in jokes and Hollywood
filmmakers are no exception tracking
down their carefully concealed Easter
eggs has become a full-time hobby for
some fans but even the most practiced I
occasionally misses something here's a
look at some well hidden Easter eggs
that flew by even the biggest movie fans
the departed it only makes sense that a
film scholar like Martin Scorsese would
pay homage to those who came before him
with some well-placed Easter eggs and he
did just that in the 2006 film The
Departed which used hidden exits on
screen to signal which characters were
going to die just like in the 1932
gangland classic Scarface even more
subtle the only straight shooter in the
film Dignam usually appears with a
straight line behind his head leave it
to Scorsese to hide an easter egg within
an easter egg Toy Story you wouldn't
expect the family-friendly classic Toy
Story to be linked with the decidedly
non family-friendly horror opus The
Shining but there are actually a number
of Easter eggs in the Toy Story
franchise referencing Stanley Kubrick's
masterpiece the first and most subtle of
them all the carpet in since house of
horrors is almost identical to the
carpet in the Shining's iconic Hotel
will never look at Woody's escape quite
the same way again Wes Craven and Sam
Raimi you really can't talk about the
history of horror movies over the last
few decades without referencing director
Sam Raimi and Wes Craven which is
fitting because the two also referenced
each other in nearly all of their
projects it began in Raimi's 1981 film
The Evil Dead which included a poster of
Cravens classic The Hills Have Eyes
Kraven answered by having a character in
1984 a Nightmare on Elm Street watched
the Evil Dead Raimi upped the ante by
placing Freddy's iconic glove in a
couple of scenes in 1987's Evil Dead 2
and the friendly rivalry even continued
into the 90s with Cravens screen showing
a group of teenagers choosing not to
watch Evil Dead that spelled out the end
of their on-screen back and forth until
after Cravens death in 2015 when Raimi
paid homage in season 2 of ash vs. Evil
Dead by once again including a poster
The Hills Have Eyes die hard with a
vengeance in the 1995 blockbuster die
hard with a vengeance John McClane is
past
what he's been doing since the events of
die hard - he responds that he's been
smoking cigarettes and watching Captain
Kangaroo
that's a nod to the Statler Brothers
song flowers on the wall which his
character in 1994's pulp fiction is
listening to during a particularly
memorable scene and the easter-egg had
extra significance because die hard with
a vengeance also featured Pulp Fiction
star samuel l.jackson neato
Zootopia you might not think frozen and
Zootopia have much in common other than
both being huge disney mega hits but
midway through Zootopia Judy and Nick
interrogate a suspect who is very
familiar to fans of frozen what were you
gonna do at those night howlers weselton
it's weaselton the character is voiced
by alan tudyk who not coincidentally
played a very similar character in
frozen the duke of weaseltown hiring the
same voice actor to set up an easter egg
now that's going above and beyond Back
to the Future in the classic Bullwinkle
segment pee buddies improbable history a
boy named Sherman travels through time
learning lessons from his mentor the
super intelligent dog Peabody if that
sounds like the premise of Back to the
Future where a boy named Marty travels
through time and learns lessons from his
mentor dr. ow don't worry because those
parallels weren't lost on the folks
making Back to the Future when Marty
arrives in the past he crashes into a
barn and encounters a wide-eyed kid who
thinks Marty is an alien that boy's name
Sherman Peabody well played fight club
David Fincher has earned a reputation as
a meticulous director over the years
with stories of actors having to suffer
through hundreds of tapes to find the
exact one he wants but even for Fincher
his keen attention to detail and Fight
Club takes the cake or the coffee he
claims to have included a Starbucks cup
somewhere in every single scene
when deep space exploration ramps up
it'll be the corporations that name
everything planet Starbucks there are
tons of subtle hints that point to the
movies big Tyler Durden plot twist but
this might be the only ongoing Easter
Egg that took a ridiculous amount of
planning to offer an uncanny commentary
on the proliferation of brand awareness
and ownership hidden in a movie that
openly denounces the corporate ownership
of human lives thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Applause]